I get a lot of emails from our yeah
we've we've got at this point over
260,000 subscribers on our youtube
channel and many people get in touch
with me in the comments or YouTube
messages or email they say David listen
I I want to support what you're doing
but I can't do it by buying a membership
I just don't have the money for that how
else can I support the show just by
watching our videos on YouTube assuming
you're not using ad block and that
you're actually watching some of the
advertisements that pop up before the
videos you're already helping us right
because YouTube ad revenue is a source
of funding for the show but there's a
lot of different things you can do
number one please follow us on social
media i'm on twitter at d pakman the
show is on twitter at david pakman show
we're on facebook at facebook.com slash
david pakman show and also engage with
other viewers in the different
communities where we exist a great
example is reddit if you go to david
pakman.com slash reddit that's our ed di
t subscribe were were surpassing two
thousand viewers who are regularly
having conversations on our edit
discussion forum we get interview and
story suggestions from reddit we I check
it daily and I love to see the back and
forth from different people in the
audience not only about politics but
also about the direction they want to
see the show go in that is a great way
to support the show helping us to set
the agenda and figure out the plan and
next steps for the show so please do
that as well and if you don't have money
to be a member but you occasionally shop
on amazon.com you can take money that
you're already paying amazon and
redirect a fraction of it to the david
pakman show all you have to do before
shopping is go to david pakman.com slash
amazon it'll redirect you to amazon you
just do your shopping no forms to fill
out nothing will look different in the
checkout process but seven to eight
percent of your purchase will get
redirected back to the david pakman show
so there are many ways to support what
we are doing without spending a penny
and the the primary one is one that most
of you are probably already doing which
is those ads that play
for our content on YouTube thanks to
everybody we are on track to hit 300,000
youtube subscribers which is going to be
a major major accomplishment and we will
be back I hope everybody's had a good
long weekend who's in the US will be
back with new shows on Monday